animals to be slaughtered is how the eu
farmers chief says the bloc's
new agriculture policies left them he
told us
more about why he thinks that well the
european commission
has not given the comprehensive
assessment
what the impact of the green deal and
farm to fork in particular
would have on europe and agriculture and
i believe that
this is quite important in order to
assess what we are up against
because european agriculture like any
agricultural sector in any part of the
world is very much
an integrated sector so you can't
extract
one sector out of it without having
a comprehensive impact to other sectors
and this of course is missing and we
would like to see the overall
impact in a sense that we could actually
make an assessment
what needs to be done and what the risks
are and this is what we have been
pushing european commission to come
forward with
the eu's 2030 farm to fork strategy then
aims to slash pesticide use by 50
percent
so-called nutrient losses and use of
anti-microbe drugs should also be cut by
the same amount
eurocrats hope by doing all that that'll
allow the blocks organic sector to
flourish in the next 10 years
indeed the eu's agriculture commissioner
says an impact assessment has been
carried out and insisted
more comprehensive reviews would be
taking place he admitted to there would
be a quote
short term negative impact from the
policies but
the farmer's representative again says
in fact in his view they're simply going
to lose
market share in general we are very much
interested in maintaining our
competitiveness and this means that
in the eyes of the consumers we need to
be competitive in both
the price and what the product
represents it's
basically price and quality ratio and
what we feel
that especially the eu internal market
there's a risk that we lose our
competitiveness if the
objectives and the principles that the
european agriculture have to accept
in as a part of the green deal and the
farm to fork
are not followed to the same letter and
that's also a part of the equation
what would be the global impact of of
the sustainability initiatives of the
european union
in our global trading patterns to our
trading partners accept
the same approach or do do they have
somewhat different
if it's different that means that we
will most probably face
unfair competition in the worst case
here in europe but certainly
internationally
you